[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi
François Fillon a été officiellement
nommé Premier ministre il a pris ses
fonctions dès ce matin à l'issue d'une
brève cérémonie avec Dominique de
Villepin qui lui a souhaité bonne chance
et avant de retrouver Nicolas Sarkozi
pour un jogging à la mi-journée dans
l'après-midi le nouveau chef du
gouvernement a procédé aux dernières
consultations pour former son équipe la
liste semble arrêtée il y aura h hommes
et SEP femmes Bernard Kouchner aurait
accepté le poste de ministre des
Affaires étrangères nous y reviendrons
longuement ce soir encore dans le reste
de l'actualité Ingrid betancour serait
vivante c'est ce que rapporte l'un de
ses compagnant de captivité qui a réussi
à s'évader il décrit des conditions de
détention éprouvantes on vote en Algérie
mais le scrutin législatif est boudé par
la population qui semble désabusé le
taux de participation était très faible
en début d'après-midi plusieurs parties
appeles au boycott enfin le deuxième
greffé du visage en France s'exprime
pour la première fois atteint d'une
maladie grave qui le défigurait il
estime que l'opération a changé sa vie
en modifiant le regard des
autres il était donné favori il a été
officiellement désigné François Fillon
est donc devenu premier ministre et
s'est installé dès ce matin à Matignon
avant d'afficher sa complicité avec
Nicolas Sarkozi lors d'une scène inédite
encore une le récit de cette longue
ourou
Carol à son arrivée à l'Élysée François
Fillon se fait un petit peu
désiré portable collé à
l'oreille et sourire
crisp il est 8h30 Nicolas Sarkozi
l'attend pour un petit
déjeuner une heure plus tard le
président de la République raccompagne
franis fon
première poignée de main officielle au
sommet de l'État monsieur
fon ministre pr ministre ministé nomé
11h c'est à pied et avec son épouse
Pénélope que François Fillon entre à
Matignon en bas des marches Dominique et
marie laord de Villepin l'épouse de
l'ancien Premier ministre a même revêtu
une veste taillée pour l'occasion au
revoir écrit dans toutes les langues
l'entretien dure une
demi-heure je voudrais
bien sûr
également souhaiter bonne chance à
François
Fillon lui dire mon espoir et ma
confiance il a tous les
atouts pour réussir au service de notre
pays les élections présidentielles ont
amené nos concitoyens à choisir une
politique nouvelle
c'est mon devoir c'est mon mandat je
respecterai tous les engagements que
nous avons pr parce que la rénovation de
la vie politique est à ce
prix largement applaudi par le personnel
Dominique de Villepin aura passé 2 ans à
Matignon pour le remplacer celui dont il
n'avait pas voulu comme ministre en
2005 c'est en short et en chaussur de
sport qu'il retrouve Nicolas Sarkozi à
l'heure du déjeuner un jogging
médiatique dans le bois de Boulogne
histoire de prouver qu'une nouvelle
génération tient désormais l'exécutif
cet après-midi exceptionnellement
Matignon vu de l'intérieur dernière
tractation derniers ajustements Bernard
couchner est là chanceo
merôo c'est peut-être la grosse surprise
du futur gouvernement et le balai
continue plus décontracté avec
rachidti plus formel avec Michel
aliomarie 18h direction l'Élysée
dernière mise au point avant l'annonce
de main du
gouvernement et avant d'enevenenir à la
composition de cette équipe on s'arrête
un instant sur le parcours de François
Fillon qui a été plusieurs fois ministre
mais qu'on connaît assez peu comme
Nicolas Sarkozi c'est un jeune
quincagénnerre il a 53 ans comme Nicolas
Sarkozi il n'a pas fait Lena pour le
reste les deux personnalités sont
dissemblables mais les deux hommes sont
très proches portrait signé Véronique
Saint-Olive Guillaume Michel courir ça
ne lui a jamais fait peur Françis Fillon
a 53 ans a du souffle de l'endurance et
il le prouve aujourd'hui dans la foulée
de Nicolas
Sarkozi pourtant en 81 François Fillon a
27 ans est plutôt du genre
timide je m'attendais pas du tout à être
élu député à 27 ans il rêvait d'être
journaliste mais il est tombé par hasard
en politique attaché parlementaire du
député Gauliste de la
SAR pour un jeune de mon âge c'est une
période exceptionnelle et que je vais
pouvoira me faire les dents à la lutte
politique dans les rang de l'opposition
et c'est auprès de Philippe sgin que
François Fillon découvre la reine
politique le premier apprécie son
intelligence le second admire son
gaulisme social ils feront ensemble la
campagne pour le nom à
mastrich mais en 95 François Fillon
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
soutient Édouard bad pour l'élection
avant de
rquourz
àure renartifici retrou FEM qui B dans
la majorité sur les mêmesan en 99 il est
le candidat malheureux contre Michel à
la présidence
r méfiant baisse bientôt la garde et en
2002 le voilà ministre des affaires
sociales du gouvernement
rfarin
etose leier il
2003 réforme des retraites
bonjour partisan de la négociation il
affronte les syndicats hostiles et les
manifestation pour l'Assemblée nationale
a adopté ce projet
de pour la première fois depuis très
longtemps un gouvernement de droite n'a
pas capitulé devant un mouvement social
victoire sur les retraites mais François
Fillon qui ne s'y attendait pas est
battu à plat de couture dans son fief au
régional
nous sommes victimes d'une lame de fond
de ce que je considère comme un 21 avril
à l'envers c'est une critique directe du
chef de l'État que celui-ci ne
pardonnera pas après un passage à
l'éducation nationale François Fillon
est éjecté du gouvernement et il
[Applaudissements]
explose quand on fera le bilan de Chirac
on ne se souviendra de rien sauf de mes
réformes en me virant du gouvernement
ils ont fait de moi un directeur de
campagne avant l'heure et il tient
parole longtemps Riv François Fillon et
Nicolas Sarkozi ne se quitteront plus
François Fillon en est sûr Nicolas
Sarkozi est le seul à pouvoir gagner en
2007 faux calme mais vrai passionné
François Fillon est un grand amateur de
cour automobile en devenant Premier
ministre il prend un nouveau départ et
cette fois c'est sur les chapeaux de rou
François Fillon a 5 enfants il est
originaire de la Sarte il a été
longtemps maire de Sablé là-bas il y a
évidemment beaucoup de fierté reportage
Julien beaumon Annie
triboir une maison sous haute
surveillance nous sommes à solemne
devant le château de François Fillon et
depuis ce matin des gendarmes gardent la
résidence du Premier ministre François
Fillon l'enfant de la Sarte il est né
ici à séran fouletourte ses parents y
habitent encore et ils ont du mal à
réaliser que leur petit François est
devenu premier ministre
on me demandait tout à l'heure quel
enfant c'était bon c'est vrai qu' il a
parlé très tôt il parlait beaucoup euh
au fond maintenant il est plutôt plus
hein plus réservé qu'il n'étaitant étant
tout petit et on est persuadé que il
réussira euh car François est un garçon
très déterminé qui a des idées très
arrêtées et qui va jusqu'au
bout mais on sait aussi que il y aura
des mauvais coups ouis forcément et on
sait très bien que intérieurement
euh il souffrira énormément un peu plus
loin son ancien instituteur ressort les
photos de classe c'était en 1960 c'est
avec lui que François Fillon ici en
clair a appris à lire c'était forcément
un très bon élève très sage très
attentif mais bon on pouvait pas savoir
[Musique]
que quel destin il aurait à l'époque
hein
c'est quand même assez
sensationnel François Fillon dans la
région c'est surtout une longue carrière
politique notamment à sabl sur Sart où
il a été maire pendant 18 ans au niveau
de l'économie il a énormément travaillé
sur sur le fait de faire venir de
nouvelles entreprises sur sablé c'est
que ça un réel plus puisqueau niveau de
l'emploi ça a quand même pas mal pé ses
fruit on peut lui dire bonjour il est
très abordable c'est quelqu'un qui fait
pas beaucoup de de commentaires mais il
avance seule inquiétude pour la
population avec ses nouvelles fonctions
François Fillon risque de venir un peu
moins souvent ici une réaction à gauche
celle de François Hollande pour le Parti
Socialiste François Fillon et tout sauf
un homme neuf comment pourrait-il
réussir dans le futur là où il a échoué
dans le passé fin de citation la
première mission de François Fillon on
l'a vu tout à l'heure est de mettre la
dernière main à la composition du
gouvernement ce soir la liste semble
définitive il y aura je vous le disais h
hommes et se femmes Arnau
longtemps il fut le rival de Nicolas
Sarkozi celui que Jacques shirac
surnommait le meilleur d'entre nous
devient probable ministre élevé au rang
de numéro 2 du gouvernement Alain jupet
jadis droit dans ses bottes pourrait
revêtir un costume écolo l'environnement
le développement durable l'énergie mais
aussi les transports autre poids lourd
Jean-Louis borlau après les affaires
social il traverseraent la scène pour
gérer à Bery la stratégie économique les
entreprises et l'emploi mais le
ministère seitind en de avec de l'autre
côté l'UMP Eric chargé des
comptes Nicolas SAR veut ouvrir sa porte
à gauche bernardch accepte l'invitation
il devrait rejoindre le au grand de ses
amis
socialistes Martin homme de gauche et
président des Maus pourrait soccuper du
logement comme secrétaire d'État
Jeanpierre jouill un proche de François
Hollande serait en charge des affaires
européenes autre main tendue cette fois
au centre l'UDF RV Morin devrait hériter
de la défense il remplacerait Michel
aliomarie qui changeant d'uniforme est
donné pour
l'intérieur c'est un ami de 30 ans du
président bris sortefeu redouit pourtant
d'être oublié mais le voilà pressenti
pour le nouveau ministère de l'Identité
nationale de l'immigration et des culte
Xavier Bertrand passerait aux affaires
sociales rachidti porte-parole pendant
la campagne pourrait devenir le nouveau
garde des sauts l'équipe Fillon contrat
15 membres dont se femmes et sauf
changement de dernière minute voici ceux
qui demain pourrai siéger au conseil des
ministres et l'annonce du gouvernement
sera à suivre en direct sur France 2 à
partir de 9h45 avec Gill Leclerc une
autre équipe est déjà en place celle qui
va entourer Nicolas Sarkozi à l'élysé
Claude Guéant sera donc son secrétaire
général Jean-David levit sera son
conseiller diplomatique Henri Guen son
conseiller spécial et Emmanuel mignon la
directrice de cabinet parmi les autres
conseillers figurent Catherine péard
journaliste au Point ainsi que Raymon
Soubi pour les questions social mais
également George Marc Benamou autre
journaliste écrivain et David Martinon
sera le porte-parole l'une de nos
équipes emmenée par Michael d'Armon et
Guillaume Viard a pu passer une partie
de la journée à l'intérieur même de
l'Élysée et assister à l'installation de
ses conseillers voici leur
reportage du QG de campagne directement
à l'éisé
chement de cadre pour les équipes de
Nicolas SAR voici les femmes et les
hommes de l'ombre du nouveau président
qu'estce que vousentez moment arrivez
dans vos bureau à l'ÉE de la
fieré la fierté et beaucoup de travail
àirant accompagne depuis plusieurs
années Nicolas SAR ici elle continuera à
s'occuper d'environnement mais tout
d'abord place au
formalités alorscolas
sjeune F ouvre les lieux et le règlement
interdit de fouler le gravier de la cour
David Martinon le porte-parole présente
les nouveaux Catherine péar jusquici la
plume politique du magazine Le Point
devient conseiller du président quant à
l'écrivain de gauche George Marc Benamou
il arrive tel le promeneur de
l'Élysée c'est une nouvelle vie j'avais
une vie d'écrivain de scénariste et
vousenez en fonction aujourd'hui oui je
crois j'arrive au bureau aujourd'hui
personne ne fuit les caméras ni les
micros comme s'il fallait dès le premier
jour montrer l'Élysée façon
Sarkozi c'est un président qui parlera
sans doute régulièrement régulièrement
et pas dans des dans des rendez-vous
annoncés à l'avance de manière
traditionnelle et chacun fait son job
Nicolas Sarkozi raccompagne François
Fillon qu'il vient de nommer à Matignon
de l'autre côté de l'Élysée Jean-David
Lévit le conseiller diplomatique planche
sur les prochains rendez-vous
internationaux il y a quelques jours il
était encore ambassadeur de France à
Washington désormais il a un surnom le
cherpa un Cherpin est un épalet qui aide
les chefs à monter au sommet en portant
le fardeau et donc de façon diplomatique
le cherpa est un diplomate qui porte une
partie du fardeau pour escalader les
sommets les sommets du G8 ah dans les
couloirs de l'Élysée on s'organise fait
un petit tour des bureau tout les
dépêche ouais vérifie ça oua à quelques
mètres du chef de l'État Henry gu qui a
été la plume du candidat Sarkozi se
prépare à être la plume du président et
de votre bureau on accè directement au
bureau du président de la République oui
à travers le secrétaire particulier qui
est juste de l'autre qui est juste là
juste derrière la porte et pour
ressortir l'escalier d'honneur première
journée à l'Élysée façon porte ouverte
le quinkena Sarkozi installe au sommet
de l'État la communication
politiqueurneouri ai et on appr que
Nicolas Sarkozi pour son premier
déplacement en France se rendra demain à
à Toulouse pour visiter le siège d'erbus
et rencontré les salariés quant à
Cécilia Sarkozi elle est arrivée cet
après-midi au port de brgançon dans lev
résidence officielle du chef de l'état
où il pourrait la rejoindre d'ailleurs
demain elle était attendue par une
petite foule de touristes chacun garde
en mémoire les image d'hier celle d'une
famille qui n'a pas l'intention
visiblement de se cacher si Nicolas
Sarkozi a imprimé son style on a compris
que celui de la première dame de France
sera également en rupture avec celle qui
l'ont précédé Véronique
Saint-Olive avec Cécilia Sarkozi c'est
depuis hier un nouveau style à l'Élysée
jamais sans ses enfants ceccilia Sarkozi
est réfractaire au corcet protocolaire
pourtant elle s'inscrit désormais dans
la lignée des premières dames de France
C femmes qui l'ont précédé au Palais de
l'Élysée sous la 5e République au cœur
du
pouvoir d'abord Yvon de Gaulle pour les
français c'était
antivon puis Claude Pompidou qui disait
que la politique la barbait Anemon
giscardestin tellement effacé Daniel
mitan tellement présente mais
ailleurs Bernadette Chirac première
maîtresse de maison à part entière
chacune à sa façon a tenu avec plus ou
moins d'enthousiasme le rôle obligé de
première dame de
France première fonction être là
discrète et souriante au côté de son
mari et puis il fallait trouver sa
place suivre les voyages
officiels s'occuper pendant la lecture
des
discours ne pas reculer devant le
protocole accueillir les invités serrer
les
[Musique]
mains et même quand il le fallait
danser je sais
que les gens et les femmes surtout
regarde la manière dont on est habillé
la manière dont on est coiffé la manière
dont on se présente c'est la règle du
jeu
exellence laie dans la grande salle des
fêtes de l'Élysée les banquets ont
toujours été interminable très collet
monté avec Anemon
giscardestin beaucoup plus frugal avec
tantvon et de la vie de Claude Pompidou
toujours très
ennuyeux
[Musique]
tout ce monde vous entoure fait tout à
votre place alors c'est pas la peine on
a donc pratiquement rien à faire si ce à
recevoir les étrangers ou partir en
voyage offici à l'étranger les premières
dames de France ont payé de le personne
pour un autre exercice le sapin de
Noël avec cadeau et goû qui va
[Musique]
avec enfant d'hier
enfant d'aujourd'hui et toujours le même
appétit à la France que j'ai pour
mission à l'Élysée Valérie giscardestin
ne laissait pas beaucoup d'espace à sa
femme elle n'en demandait pas plus et je
crois
qu'emon veut aussi vous exprimer ses
vœux à tous et à toutes j'exprime mes
vœux très
chaleureux que cette année nouvelle vous
apporte le bonheur la santé et le
succès pour vous et pour ceux que vous
aimez à l'exacte opposé Daniel miteran
s'engage personnellement en politique
elle utilise son statut de femme de
président pour défendre les populations
opprimés aux quatre coins du monde comme
les Kurdes qui fuissent Adam
husin je n'ai pas l'impression d'être
discrète par exemple quand je mène des
actions dans le monde pour auprès des
plus démunis c'est elle qui fait venir
par F Castro en froid avec lestats-unis
c'est elle qui le fait recevoir à
l'Élysée par le
président l'Élisée bernadetteac est la
première à s'y sentir bien elle y vit
c'est chez elle elle veut en faire la
vitrine de la France plan de table
cuisine elle s'occupe de tout elle
veille à
toutagverise de Gir le jardin aussi la
passionne avec parois MIG
pas peut-être on sa'est pas compris
est-ce qu'on peut encore rattraper et
mettre beaucoup de rosiers là alors
quand Bernadette chira quitte l'Élysée
c'est pour la corise dont elle est l'élu
local ou pour s'occuper de sa fondation
des hôpitaux de France elle y gagne une
vraie popularité son moteur à elle pour
faire de la politique jusqu'au
bout nouvelle génération Cecilia Sarkozi
ne veut rien abandonner mais il lui
reste à trouver ses marques au côté de
son mari président et à dessiner à sa
façon la place qui est des désormais la
sienne dans le reste de l'actualité
d'abord des nouvelles d'Ingrid betancour
elle serait vivante c'est ce qu'indique
un policier ancien otage également de la
guerria colombienne qui a réussi à
s'évader il dit l'avoir rencontré pour
la dernière fois il y a 3 semaines c'est
un soulagement pour la famille qui reste
toutefois prudente Jacques cardos Pascal
Caron l'air ragar le visage est Maé ran
Pinchao est apparu en conférence de
presse encore choqué par ces années de
captivité cet ancien aconte qu'il a d
briser ses ches avant de marcher 17
jours dans la forêt
colombienne puis les journalistes
l'interrogent sur ses compagn de
détention la dernière fois que je les ai
vu j'étais en compagnie des TR
américains Tom et Mar souff d'une
hépatite y avaour ASI que le sénateur
PZ jusque là la dernière preuve de vie
remonta à cette vidéo diffusée en
septembre 2003 depuis les informations
sur Ingrid Bétancour sont minces on sait
qu'elle a été enlevée sur cette route et
selon ce nouveau témoignage qu'elle
pourrait avoir été détenu au moins
pendant un temps dans la zone de
vitchada près du Brésil Méan en cours sa
fille veut rester prudente car les
souvenirs de l'exotage à propos de sa
mère ne semble pas très précis c'est la
première fois que quelqu'un qui qui a
été avec maman euh pendant un certain
temps on ne sait pas quand on ne sait
pas à quel moment mais qu' a vu
euh va va va un peu nous raconter
quelque chose donc c'est comm même
quelque chose qui nous vient de de très
loin c'est très émouvant aujourd'hui la
famille veut lancer un nouvel appel à
l'équipe présidentielle de Nicolas
Sarkozi nous demandons en tant que
famille l'intervention du président
Nicolas Sarkozi auprès du président
hribé de manière à ce qu'il lu fasse
comprendre que toute opération militaire
est exclue pour essayer de délivrer nos
otages les autorités colombiennes vont
maintenant interroger avec plus de
précision l'ancien policier elles
obtiendront des informations cruciales
sur cour mais rien ne dit qu'elles en
feront profiter les autorités
françaises les élections législatives en
Algérie apparemment elle ne passionne
pas une population désabusée semble-t-il
par le chômage et les attentats qui ont
repris il y a eu un mort hier à
Constantine Abdelaziz boutflica a voulu
montrer l'exemple en votant près de son
domicile dans un quartier up d'Alger
sans faire d'ailleurs de déclaration
mais il a été peu suivi et à 15h le taux
de participation était inférieur à 20 %
il faut dire que les députés ont de
pouvoir en Algérie et que la situation
politique semble plus verrouillée que
jamais envoyé spéciau samou
Mathias dans ce bureau de vote de la
banlieu d'Alger comme dans la plupart il
fallait être patient pour croiser un
électeur les Algériens ont manifestement
Boué les urnes
38 le nombre d'inscrit c'est
317 et le nombre de votant 38 et chez
ceux qui sont venus voter pas
d'enthousiasme et bien peu de convi
on vote en se disant peut-être ils vont
enfin nous voir peut-être ils vont
s'occuper de nous on sait jamais en face
du bureau de vote l'indifférence
générale comme tous les jours l'attente
le désuvrement cela bootte les c'est
question de confiance pour pas faire
confiance à n'importe le qui ils nous
font des promesses et rien ne vient moi
par exemple je suis marié je vis chez
mes parents sans travail sans ri
dans la même zone le bidonville de Ben
bouid ni eau ni électricité un des tris
camicas qui s'est fait sauter le mois
dernier à Alger habitait
ici son frère ignorait tout des liens de
son aîné avec alqaïda il a appris la
nouvelle comme tout le monde à la
télévision la pauvreté qui l'a poussé
sans la misère mon frère n'aurait jamais
folie des attentats ven rappel que les
problèmes socix qui avent Nour les
isamist pas disparu malgré la manne
pétrolière et gazière à 70 ans cette
habitante désespère devant la situation
des plus jeunes la plupart il prend un
panier ils vont chercher du pain sec ils
vont le vendre la plupart ils vont
chercher du fer des casserol de de tout
ce qu'il y a dans le quartier mais aucun
candidat n'est venu ici pour s'en rendre
compte à défaut de colère le sentiment
dominant chez les Algériens aujourd'hui
est l'indifférence face à un pouvoir
politique qu'il juge inamovible et
incapable de résoudre leurs problèmes à
l'étranger encore et en bref les trains
de la réconciliation pour la première
fois depuis la fin de la guerre en 1953
des convois ont franchi la frontière
entre la Corée du Sud et la Corée du
Nord il ne s'agit pour l'instant que
d'un test car la dictature communiste
nord-coréenne refuse l'établissement
d'une ligne régulière retour en France
et retour maintenant sur ce projet
d'enlèvement d'une fillette par des
pédophiles qui a été déjoué un projet
préparé sur Internet on en parlait hier
internet qui peut parfois être un piège
pour des enfants ou des adolescents trop
crédules c'est bien sûr aux parents de
les mettre en garde de les encadrer mais
des formations sont aussi proposé
parfois à l'école ou au collège dossier
signé Laeticia le gendre Guillaume
fautra lorsque vous naviguez sur
Internet c'est un peu comme lorsque vous
marchez dans la rue vous pourrez tomber
sur des personnes de confiance et les
personnes qui vont essayer en sorte de
vous arnaquer ce sera pas marqué sur
leur front attention Truant sur Internet
c'est pareil c'est un til très pratique
mais il faut toujours être à l'affu il a
pénétré la grande majorité des foyers
français internet s'est imposé comme un
outil de recherche formidable qui n'est
pourtant pas sans risque pour les plus
jeunes sexe violence racisme les pièges
foisonnes un tiers des enfants aurait
déjà été victimes de ce côté obscur de
la toile je devais faire un exposé sur
les escargots j'avais tapé
escargot j'étais tombé sur des choses
qui faisait référence à des escargots
mais céit pas des
escargots donc des images
pornographiques ouais on sent quoi à ce
momentl on s agressé non on s pas
agressé mais on pense que les gens
peuvent être bêtes parce que mettre ça à
la place d'escargot marche pas ça choque
énormément et on est gûé on essaie de
fermer de temps en temps ça se rouvre
sans qu'on le veuille et c'est gênant on
en parle aux parents non non parce qu'
ils peuvent penser que justement on est
allé dessus exprès nous viennent des
États-Unis méfiance aussi vis-à-vis de
certains blogs ventant l'anorexie et là
où ces sites FR sont dangereux c'est que
N non seulement il vous incite à devenir
anorexique mais à travers des blogs ou à
travers des forums les personnes qui
font partie de ce système se lancent des
défis exemple de défi ne pas manger
pendant tout un weekend lorsque vous
acceptez un contact la seule chose que
vous
voyez c'est la photo alors vigilance par
rapport au contenu mais méfiance aussi
vis-à-vis des pseudos et des internautes
eux mêmes les messageries instantanées
sont devenus un terrain de jeu privilégé
pour les adolescents vous prenez tout
pour argent content mais aussi pour les
pédophiles elle a cru vraiment que j'éta
un adolescent hein ça t'est arrivé toi
de quand te fixes des rendez-vous de
personnes que tu ne connais pas on m'a
proposé mais j'y suis pas y to pensé
quoi
euh en fait je l'ai un peu envoyé
balader il existe bien des logiciels de
filtrage mais peu de parents connaissent
l'existence de ces
programmes c'est pas leur grand pr fort
du du coup il surveill pas extrêmement
mais font quand même attention il y a un
logiciel de filtrage ben non il SAV pas
comment on
fait autant chez les enfants on sent on
sent qu'il y a un début de prise de
conscience chez les parents on en est
toujours au statut quo à savoir un gros
souci une peur d'en parler avec les
enfants et un manque de réalisme quant à
la nécessité de de prendre à pleine main
cet enjeu d'éducation même discours mais
cette fois le public a changé c'est aux
parents désormais que la prévention
s'adresse ils parlent de toute leur vie
sur leur blog leur blog il est où sur
inter internet quelques milliards
d'utilisateurs pour des adultes souvent
dépassés désemparés par l'outil
informatique et complexité Jeur plus
internet chez moi je TR ça
effrayant je me dis que il faut pas
avoir internet chez soi c'est quandme
grave tout ça a du mal à les suivre fait
il connaissent la méthode technique mais
connaissent pas forcment les
conséences faess regarder un peu mais je
suis pasère temp je pas
ça pas plus de danger qu'autre chose
mais on fait attention à l'alimentation
de son fils on fait attention à sa santé
on devit faire attention à Internet vous
voyez ses parents repartiront avec
quelques conseils pratiques comme
installer l'ordinateur dans une pièce
commune parler d'internet en famille
définir des horair et des règles
strictes d'utilisation un rempart bien
fragile pour surfer en toute
sérénité économie on en parle depuis
longtemps cette fois c'est en bonne voie
le prix des appels vers l'étranger à
partir d' téléphone portable devrait
diminuer de façon conséquente un accord
en tout cas été trouvé au niveau
européen Vincent fourc Dani
triboir pour faire grimper sa facture de
téléphone mobile il existe une technique
imparable passer la frontière ainsi
quand le client d'un opérateur français
passe un coup de fil depuis un autre
pays d'Europe sa communication lui
revient en moyenne quatre fois plus cher
qu'en France la différence passe dans ce
qu'on appelle le roaming c'est-à-dire ce
que doit payer une personne pour
utiliser à l'étranger un autre réseau
que le sien exemple avec notre abonné
français qui téléphone depuis l'Italie
il débourse de 50 centimes à 1,18 € la
minute l'abonné italien lui 10 centimes
seulement mais l'Union européenne veut
plafonner ses tarifs à l'étranger
l'appel émis ne devra pas coûter plus de
49 centimes la minute l'appel reçu pas
plus de 24 centimes toujours trop cher
pour les associations de
consommateurs le coût pour l'opérateur
est de 012 € hors taxes et les tarifs
proposés euh qui sont de 0,49 € hors
taxes sont bien déconnectés et il n'y a
aucune réalité économique pour proposer
de tels plafonds cette mesure européenne
pourrait entrer en vigueur à l'automne
une bonne nouvelle pour les 147 millions
d'Européens qui chaque année utilisent
leur mobile hors de chez eux la France
redoute la sécheresse hier les
départements des ivelines près de Paris
et des bouchesdô Marseille ont été
placés en état de vigilance c'est-à-dire
des mesures de restriction sont proches
d'année en année le manque d'eau devient
chronique certains constructeurs l'ont
compris et on voit se multiplier des
maisons équipées de récupérateurs d'eau
de pluie reportage dans le gare Florence
griffon Françoise Mazou donc voilà la
citerne de 4500 l qui est ici équipé de
deux
filtres donc l'eau est récupérée par la
station
propageci est envoyé sur le sur un
réseau spécifique pour le pour le
pluvial cet équipement ce particulier
l'a acheté il y a un an et demi d'abord
pour son jardin nous sommes à quelques
kilomètres du pont du gare ici l'eau est
précieuse la cuve permet une quasi
autonomie il peut arriver que la cuve se
vide notamment en période en période
sèche mais bon c'est des périodes assez
courte on peut on peut estimer que
9 mois de l'année on est on a de l'eau
en permanence alors là vous avez le
réseau d'eau pluvial là vous avez le
réseau de ville avec cette séparation
les eau de pluie ne se mélangent pas aux
eau de ville seul les toilettes et la
machine à laver sont raccordé à la cuve
avantage les bactéries ne se propagent
pas dans les autres tuyaux l'eau pour la
rousage qui des bactéries ça ça aucune
importance pour ce qui est du laveelinge
l'eau est chauffée à une température
suffisante pour pour pas avoir de
problème et dans les toilettes des
bactéries il y en a je vous le dis il y
a pas de souci il y en a déjà
l'équipement complet lui a coûté 8000 €
à ce prix là les particuli préfèrent en
général des cuves qui ne servent que
pour le jardin et ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux ation pu c'est ce que
constate ce professionnel il vient de
livrir une cuve à enterrer d'après lui
deux gros orages suffisent à la remplir
on a besoin de l'ouvrir tous les combien
une fois par an mais s'il y avait
beaucoup d'arbres un petit peu plus
souvent pour nettoyer le filtre tout le
monde dans le Midi attend se dire je pas
récupérer le PL parce qu'il ne pleut pas
alors que en fait il pleut autant que
dans les autres régions mais de manière
plus soudaine et plus abondante cette
cuveel revient à environ 2600 € il faut
attendre au minimum 8 ans pour l'amortir
mais les fleurs et le potager nurontû
que l'eau du ciel santé l'homme qui a
bénéficié de la deuxième greffe du
visage en France s'exprime pour la
première fois il a 27 ans il a été opéré
en janvier dernier une maladie grave le
défigurait il estime que l'opération a
changé sa vie en modifiant le regard des
autres vous pourrez entendre
l'intégralité de cette interview ce soir
dans un documentaire sur notre antenne
Antoine
gavou c'était Pascal il y a 5 mois 27
ans et le visage totalement déformé par
une maladie rare et curable la maladie
de Von re Kling Azon il essayait alors
tant bien que mal d'avoir une vie à peu
près
normale voil merci voilà au
revoir seul moyen pour changer
d'apparence une greffe du visage bonjour
bonjour elle a été réalisée en janvier
dernier à l'hôpital Henri Mondor de
créteille par le professeur lantierie
verteuille verte 15h d'Opération Nez
bouche menton et joues sont remplacés
c'est seulement la troisème fois qu'une
telle intervention est réalisée dont
deux fois par des médecins
français l'enje il est social et c'est
là la difficulté c'est de savoir si dans
dans sa demande sociale cette gre de
cette transplantation va lui permettre
de réintégrer une vie sociale normale 15
jours plus tard les petits gestes du
quotidien sont enfin possibles Pascal
s'habitue peu à peu à son nouveau visage
on peut dire que d'ici un an nous aurons
un visage qui permettra à Pascal de
circuler dans la rue sans être regardé
par les autres ne plus être dévisagé une
autre vie commence pour lui comme pour
ses
proches il y aura bientôt d'autres
opérations il faudra notamment remettre
en place la mâchoire et les dents pour
que Pascal puisse enfin être un homme
comme les
autres Nau vis nelle vie c'est un
documentaire à suivre dans la case
infrarouge à partir de 22h25 ce soir
donc sur France 2 le festival de Cann
sur les marches ce soir Sophie Marceau
en smoking blanc Jacques vergess un
documentaire sur la vie de l'avocat va
être présenté demain et puis Juliette
Binoche pour un film sélectionné dans la
catégorie Un certain regard mais
l'événement de la soirée était sur
l'écran un film choc un polar zodiaque
de David Fincher l'auteur de Seven un
film qui a fait très forte impression
Pascal Deschamp Nadine
Picard 12 ans après le mythic s le
réalisateur David Fincher s'attaque un
nouveau tueur en série le légendaire
zodiaque bien réel celui-là sans doute
le plus célèbre de l'Amérique il fit la
une à la fois des années 60 en répondant
la terreur dans la région de San
Francisco et ne fut jamais
arrêté il vient
nous ah monu il a
unee
minutiusement 2 une éigme dense et
complexe le zodiaque revendi ses
meurtres en envoyant des lettr crypté au
journaux dans lesquels il Nar la
police quand les spectateurs sortiront
du film ils se diront le zodiaque est là
dehors et ça c'est vraiment tout
l'intérêt du
film auur l'oirenag
onéellect
ber qui la surprise générale repris
l'enquête se littéralement obsd
j'aicherier Touta beso pour le créer
trouve dans
livr j'ai
dire
hé il
paspecteur n'arrive pas à mettre la main
sur le meurtrier alors il aésespérment
essayé de
faire j'ai besoin de savoir qui
c'est j'ai besoin d'être là j'ai besoin
de le regarder dans les yeux et j'ai
besoin de savoir que c'est
lui malgré l'arrestation de quelques
suspect on ne sait toujours pas
aujourd'hui qui était le zodiaque
contrairement à la plupart des thrillers
le film ne finit donc pas par
l'arrestation du méchant zodiaque le
récit d'une tragique impuissance et le
film sort aujourd'hui dans les salles en
France c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météoalie
20h50 Krakatoa un documentaire fiction
sur la plus grande éruption volcanique
de l'histoire très bonne
[Musique]
soirée